going back to your point about about
democrats you know one of the reasons
that that motivated my
my uh deregistering from the party you
know i mean as a black person you're
just expected to be a democrat but
you i i you can't honestly
ignore the fact that you have all of
these uh
cities that have uh large black
populations
that um that are afflicted with blight
all kinds of disparities you know
between rich and poor you know crime
and they're run by democrats in many
instances they're run they've been run
by democrats for decades and yet people
still keep supporting them so
and and you know and and i got backlash
on twitter when i'm like you know well
i'm not going to vote for democrats just
automatically they they they they're
taking our vote for granted
they piss on your face and they're
telling you it's raining they do it all
the time and and black people just eat
it up and i just i'm just
you know i i'm all about black
empowerment but for me my empowerment
is you know not
not automatically subscribing to any one
world view or any party it's like you
know you want to earn my vote then earn
my vote don't just
assume that i'm gonna go there and you
can just say things and be like oh white
people white people white people and i'm
gonna be like
oh okay yeah i'll just go along with it
i'm that guy i'll tell you what i see
i see a big part of the problem is right
so you
said everyone you've met knows about
emmett till ian didn't i was talking
about my friend who said you know i'm
surprised people don't teach about
juneteenth and i'm like they taught us
when we were in school
yeah the irony what these people these
these progressives and these leftists
and many of them i get it good-natured
righteous indignation the problems
they're talking about are in
democrat-run cities like you mentioned
so when you complain about police
brutality
you're not talking about rural idaho
you're talking about new york city
when you mention stop and frisk new york
city when you talk about racially
segregated neighborhoods like redlining
that was chicago the red line it's the
train line it's called the red line they
called it redlining
these things were all happening in
cities run by democrats for like a
hundred years
so maybe maybe you got issues i look
i've been to
conservative parts of the south very
racist places i've been i've been a lot
of them
uh people people have their own world
views based on where they live
and i think one of the issues is that
these these progressives live in cities
and then they treat the whole country
like a city block
in manhattan and they do it with the
media like that the media
gets into all the cities it's even like
culture politics downstream from culture
you know
fantastic concepts they'll go to a bar
in manhattan
and then attribute their experience to
rural idaho and then they'll make a
commercial
and show it on tv in rural idaho and
start messing with people and it's it's
so incidental
it's so having spent 15 years in new
york i mean you you
it's such uh it's such an enveloping
experience
and even i have to stop myself from
from um i have to remind myself that not
you know this is just a really unique
place to be and not everywhere is like
this and not everywhere should be
like this and you know new yorkers
you know they think they're smarter than
everybody else and they think that
everywhere should be like new york but
then when you leave new york people are
like man like new york
i don't care you're from new york right
you know you yankee yada yada yada like
they just they just don't care nobody
thinks that nobody thinks that new
yorkers are as cool as new yorkers do
yeah were you in manhattan oh yeah
people in manhattan were like brooklyn's
not new york
well but everyone everyone and everyone
in new york agrees staten island is in
new york even people from stanford
well but but also there's this i mean
it's i've spoken to people brilliant
people who you know
they say for instance you know i don't
like those flyover country people people
who have grown up in the lap of
affluence and privilege
say i don't like these but i'm like dude
as soon as you leave manhattan
the rest of the state is pretty red
right you know i mean
you can go upstate you know and you can
fight you can see trump signs i mean you
know
maybe even a confederate flag or two you
know maybe yeah and
it's so i'm like dude you're you're
you're even
they're bubbles they're they're they're
in their games you're crapping on your
own people they're they're in bubbles
and the bubbles are actually getting
smaller and smaller in physical space
but denser in population
yeah so you go outside new york even a
couple miles it's red
yeah you start seeing a bunch of
republicans and trump supporters and
i'll say you know
i'll say this too um just in terms of
the the coveted response i mean that
that in and of itself i mean i feel like
i have a bit of a unique experience in
terms of
having lived in the city at the start of
the pandemic i was one of the people i
mean i was sanitizing my mail and my
groceries back in january and february
man i was
i was stocking up on food i was telling
my friends in fact i still have nitrile
gloves left over from when i from when i
uh stocked up on supplies and someone
thought it was like so that means you
robbed
uh uh medical professionals of like much
needed gear i was like oh my god
but but you know but then you go to they
were saying back then man they were but
don't wear them ass they said
that's crazy yeah thanks uh in general
but then when you go to um
a place like atlanta where it's it's way
more relaxed and then you come back to
new york i mean new york right now
uh i mean i'm in this chat group on on
twitter uh and
it's a lot of lefties and liberals who
are against the lockdown
measures and a lot of us are in new york
a lot of us met up in new york last time
i was there
and i'm you know if you live in new york
city
you are inundated every moment of your
life once you leave your your
your apartment your shoe box with you
know there's
arrows on the ground telling you where
to walk there's little circles telling
you where to stand you know inside and
outside there's
there's advertisements everywhere
telling you to wear your mask there's
train announcements there's digital
advertise there's it's every it's
everywhere get you know get your vaccine
stay away from each other
mask up don't wear it underneath your
nose where i mean it's just it's
constant it's constant it's constant
then you go to atlanta
and i mean i make this point on twitter
like you can go get a lap dance
in atlanta right now and no one cares
you know i mean i work at a nightclub
down there no one's wearing masks inside
because they want to get out and party
and like they it's not that they don't
care it's just that
you know it's it's just a whole
different vibe when you come to new york
and everyone is like walking around
outside with their masks on and they're
just
they're they're afraid and they're not
socializing and it's it's a totally
different world but they don't know it
because they're
in this bubble in new york and they just
and they watch the news all the time and
they just
they don't know look you look at like uh
in response to texas opening up
you get michael moore and keith
olbermann saying take the vaccines away
from texas
everyone's like die yeah yeah exactly
and it's like dude you realize like
just just like a little bit less than
half of texas votes democrat like
like it was very close between you know
was it beto and ted cruz
were there running i think yeah it was
like pretty close and so a bunch of even
leftists and democrats were like
guys please there are democrats who live
in texas you don't want any of them to
die and they're like
there was one tweet from this guy and he
was like furthermore republicans
shouldn't die either simply because they
voted for a republican that's insane
that these prominent progressives say
this but look at you know look at who
these people are limousine
liberal keith oberman and michael you
know michael moore they live
in the the bosom of wealth in ultra
liberal
cities i don't exactly know where
they're living right now but they're
totally
in this weird bubble surrounded by other
weirdos
who think this is popular opinion and
even regular like
even media democrats who have all of
their biases we always complain about
them we're like dude
dude come on like we don't want
republicans to die from the virus
yeah we can complain about the governor
and stuff but like florida's been open
the whole time and i'm like you're here
dude like i agree man
i think it's just one of the problems is
that
you have personalities like this like
like older men like mike moore
who it's the definition of a grifter you
know what i mean
they love to point the fingers in my
direction and i'm like dude i'll just
say whatever i feel like saying
michael moore trying to rile people up
to the point where he actually says take
the vaccines away
or maybe they shouldn't have vaccines
and keith olbermann saying they
shouldn't have vaccines
i'm like not even not even leftists were
like saying that because
you actually have people on the left who
have opinions i disagree with some of
their opinions i agree with some of
their opinions
and i think many of them genuinely
believe what they believe
but i look at people like older men or
more when they say say stuff like that
i'm like they don't believe any of this
they're just saying what they think will
rile up enough people to get a bunch of
retweets and it worked
they're they're part of they're part of
the quote unquote intelligentsia
and you know i also notice a trend among
a lot of these people i mean
i often say that twitter is a place
where you you you can get away with
saying things that would get you punched
in the face in real life
and a lot of these so-called radicals or
whatever there's a
there's a guy that i follow i i follow
him explicitly because i disagree with
him so vehemently he's a socialist
i'm not going to say what his name is
but you know he
he's he's tweeting the most overheated
hyperbolic melodramatic rhetoric about
you know we have to overthrow the
capitalistic system and
you know every time there's a black
person holiday he's like you know
malcolm x
and then you watch a video you know and
he's just the most
i mean how i mean i don't know how to
describe it but you know he just he
sounds like this
i'm like of course you sound like that
because when it when when when the
revolution goes down
you ain't gonna be nowhere to be found
you you know you
like if you're he's gonna be one of
those people who's like he's gonna have
a gun and be like oh i don't
i don't know what to do with with this
and oh people are punching people like i
don't know what to do
it's the softest people who have the
most s to talk
it's all like every time you know start
like i've been i've been getting more i
became more of a gun person in the past
year because of most because of the
riots
yes you have i'm finding bullets just
randomly around the house by the way
it's it's actually pretty hilarious
well they're not it's not random it's
not random okay
you know what it is it is strategic but
i won't get into too much detail because
you know
security at the house and everything
like that but it isn't random and
i started you know going to the range we
mentioned this earlier in the show
like give someone a handgun who's never
fired before
man will they not be able to make it
work and so the people who
there's a lot of new gun owners a lot a
lot of liberals went out and bought guns
and i hope hope hope hope any of you
listening who are new gun owners
you go take some classes you go to a
local range
you ask people to give you all the tips
in the world because
you do like you need to respect you know
like what it means to be
a well-versed and the rules the safety
uh how to actually
shoot when the revolution comes a lot of
these people who are you know
on the left they're not gonna know how
to operate a gun at all no and so
there's a joke
where a lot of conservatives say this
they were like i i can't remember
exactly what the joke is i'm sure people
listening will know it but it's
something like
you know thank you to all of the uh
liberals who are buying supplies
you're collecting them for the people
who own guns you know which is like the
conservatives because
when it really comes down to it what are
you gonna do you know
when when people are are getting violent
it's it's the craziest thing when i have
these conversations with people and they
don't think anything bad is happening
because we are truly frogs in a pot
boiling
i hear a lot of people saying like tim
you were scaremongering about civil war
or whatever and i was like yeah and then
like 800 people started into the u.s
capitol building i guess so
was i wrong like i didn't say the
apocalypse was gonna have apocalypse was
gonna happen and like we're gonna see
meteors fall from the sky and the whole
planet was gonna blow up
i said people are gonna start escalating
the violence and the tensions
and it's literally happening and i don't
see any reason why it would stop at this
point
because they're still just ramping
things up global civil war
this this fifth that's gonna call fifth
dimensional fifth generational war but
it doesn't have to be world war
one country yeah but it's like a civil
world war like it's an economic
world war or a political world war right
now it's
it's it's a weird time of of upheaval
you know what i mean it's very very
it's weird it's unique and and i think
that's the issue too is too too much
we we have that saying right those who
forget their history are doomed to
repeat it
well there should be another saying
where it's like those who think the
future will be based on the past
100 percent are fools i don't know it's
not a good quote but you get the idea
right you can't look at 1860s
and be like that's going to happen today
it's like what are you talking about we
have phones
yeah you know what i mean like we have
the internet like there's just
artificial intelligence this is like
yeah seriously and
nuclear bombs you know it's not going to
be the same conflict you know uh
back in the day i love talking about
this because it's a point people don't
realize
could you imagine during the civil war
sending a message from dc to like
fort sumter and you're like how do we
get a message there put it on horseback
and then it'll be there in a week today
it's like let me just text jim
yep you got the message all right
they're moving out it's just like the
instant
instantaneous transmission of
information has changed everything
totally totally
so what we experience is gonna be very
very different it's not gonna be you
know like the past yeah
you know i don't i don't know how things
are going to work out i mean i
i i am curious um what is his name
michael malus who talks about uh you
know all this chaos is actually good
because on the other
side of it um you know we're gonna come
out better for it and maybe
maybe he's right i mean maybe maybe
that's part of why people like me are
popping up because we're saying you know
more and more of us are saying like no
this is not okay i don't i'm not okay
with the way things are going
um but at the same time
whatever happens in terms of getting to
that place that whatever that that
proverbial better place might be i mean
maybe that it that actually now that i
think about it that might be another
form of utopianism
in a way it's like you know what's on
the other side of that it's no place
have you ever watched star trek
i watched the next generation like back
in the day best one of the best shows
ever made
one of my all-time favorite shows and
i'm just like i look at this vision of
the future
where you've got people of all different
race and species
they work together there's alliances and
i'm just imagining like
this this air this 90s era liberalism
that truly believed
in treating people based on the content
of their character resulted in this idea
and it wasn't even 90s i mean you go
back to the original star trek and they
had like the first interracial kiss
right you know right yeah
wrong one oh no oh oh they're all going
to come they're going to come after me
now yeah
but so so it was always fairly
progressive and then in the 90s
it brings about this this this vision of
a future where people are all getting
along and judging people on the content
of their character
could you imagine star trek today where
it's like
an alien race comes in they're like how
many arms you have okay you have no arm
privilege but you are psychic oh you
have psychic privilege
and it's like a show based on that world
view would just be
it would just be like the most painfully
dystopian nightmare
yeah not a good idea for a future i like
this idea where we're all just like
we're gonna get on a spaceship and go to
space i don't care what you look like
can you press the button
great let's do it you know what i mean i
feel like the the
the previous show that you mentioned
however even though nobody would watch
it i guarantee you would get at least a
90
on rotten tomatoes i i shouldn't be
showered
oh yeah it would be like one percent
audience rating but like one hundred
percent
certified exactly exactly i think i
think we should uh film a sketch
like that but not be explicit in the
comedy of it
like literally just make woke star trek
as like a short like three minute little
little bit
and just see if that happens take it
seriously
take it seriously yeah yeah bill like
the captain has to be
like a disabled person of color who's
non-binary
and you know because a privilege is not
going to be given to the white male or
whatever and then
a certain species comes in and it's like
a floating mass and it has no legs it
has no color and so the like it has
no known privilege you know something
like that
that would be excellent i think i think
the um i think
the the captain should be oh gosh it
should be a
a fat black transgendered paraplegic in
a hijab that should be the captain
of this of this star trek series thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you